You've seen the dismal situation we're
in. So, what's the solution?
To recap, let's summarize where we're
at, which is basically Okay, a lot of
European nations people have are fed up
with Islam. You know, we we we get it,
they say. We don't want it, we're done,
and it needs to go. We don't want to
deal with it anymore. And we saw three
different possible approaches. The first
one's the extreme one, which is we've
had enough of Islam, we want nothing to
do with this. We don't want Islam in our
Western country, our European country,
let's say. All right? So, what does that
mean? That means no more migration, and
we want the Muslims are gone. All right,
maybe the former, that's the only thing
we can talk about, the migration.
Getting rid of your host Muslim society
in the current climate, I don't see that
as any way, shape, or form possible.
This would require, imagine the
government of, let's say, the UK going
to Muslim homes saying, "Oh, you're a
Muslim, you have to leave. Go back to
wherever, North Africa or the Middle
East." Okay? Now, again, is that humanly
possible? Of course, much worse has
happened historically. But, is that
plausible in the current climate? I
don't think so at all. Why? Because
we've seen the reaction just from
countries trying to get rid of illegal
aliens who are criminal elements, and
people are having a hissy fit about it
in the United States, right? And the
United States is generally seen as less
liberal than, let's say, the UK.
So, how can you even begin to imagine
something like that? Okay? So, park
number one on the side. Number two,
fine, we're going to keep our Muslims,
but no more Muslim migration.
And the ones who are here, well, we're
going to we have to get serious. We have
to make it clear to them that we're not
going to have any of this
radicalization, jihad business. You
know, we're going to monitor their
mosques, and we're going to Good luck
with that, okay? Because, one, I don't
think your society has the fortitude to
do that, cuz it's going to be called
names. It's going to be called racist
and Islamophobe. And that's all that
most people in the West need to
capitulate and fall down on their face
and cry, right? So, that's not going to
happen. And even if you could do this, I
gave you the Granada example with Spain,
which means, yeah, I guess what? Our
Muslims will say, "Fine. And we will
become model, whatever, French citizens,
British citizens, model Christians,
however you want it. We'll do it. But in
our hearts, because this is a long, deep
doctrine, we will still hate and work
against you." So, that won't work. Third
option. Okay, no more migration and
current Muslims, just please like us.
>> [laughter]
>> And that's where you're at, okay? This
is the realistic point where you're at
right now. And we've just seen that that
right there, again, good luck with the
migration. I mean, uh sometimes I talk
as if that can be done. I don't know if
that can be done. We've already seen how
hard it is for these Look in the United
States, just getting rid of illegal
immigrants. So, is that going to happen
in Europe? Are they going to be hounding
and getting getting rid of illegal
Muslim migrants, right? But more
importantly is the demographic issue,
because you have Islam embedded in your
society. What's going to happen is
they're having children. You're not. Not
you per se, but your society in general
is Some of them are in the negative
replacement, okay? The birth rates are
much, much, much higher. Are you not
aware that in so many European capitals,
usually, the number one newborn name for
baby boys is Muhammad? Think about that.
>> [laughter]
>> That's just Again, this is the sort of
thing which just shows you how
desensitized people are, cuz they hear
that and they're like, "Yeah, well, so
no big deal." You're desensitized
because you see it in your society and
you've been born and bred into thinking
you have to be You always are a
second-class citizen in your own
society. That's what you've been taught.
So, it's not weird. But if you actually
look If you were to envision and try to
see this in another setting, it would
never make sense. What What if I told
you that in I don't know, in India, the
newborn name of baby boys is John, and
it's all like Germans? Would that kind
of be a little weird? Would you be
wondering, like, "What's up with that?"
I think you would. But because it's
happening in your society and you've
been taught and bred and indoctrinated
and socially engineered into accepting
it because you're multicultural, you're
diverse, you're open-minded, you're not
a bigot. You don't see it, okay? So, the
demographic things in the third in the
third and most plausible scenario is
that, okay, let's say you manage by some
miracle to stop or slow down migration,
your your current Muslim population is
going to outbreed you. It's just a
matter of time, okay? All right, so
what? So, those that's the that's the
reality as dismal as it is and as
black-pilled as I am, you know, what can
I tell you? You have to deal with it.
So, why? The first thing you have to
understand is to actually address this
in a realistic way and try to it let's
say it's a nation that says we want to
be done with Islam. The reason you can't
do it is because it requires a paradigm
shift. It's not just limited to, oh,
we're going to remain the way we are,
but we're going to get rid of Islam.
Can't do that. It's all interconnected,
okay? Everything is interconnected.
Well, what am I talking about? I'm
talking about this dominance disgusting
leftist epistemology, ideology that
dominates Western societies, okay?
You're not going to get rid of Islam and
maintain that. There's no way. They are
connected. So, I'm trying to get to the
root cause to show you what the root
issue is. The root issue isn't, oh, I'm
going to get rid of Islam. You can't do
that. You are paralyzed. Why are you
paralyzed? Because the dominant spirit
of the age, the dominant ideology that
controls you, what is flippantly called
the leftist, and I hate that word
because it doesn't begin to do justice
of what it really is, exists to protect
Islam. But, it also promotes all sort of
mental sicknesses, all sorts of evil
sexual perversion, okay? It insists
there's no absolutes, there's no truths,
and it also promotes a sort of
selfishness that leads to childlessness,
going back to the demographic thing.
That is the real issue at hand here.
This is the reason the Islam issue is a
problem, okay? Because of the current
geist, the current spirit of the age
that animates and dominates Western
society, which most Western people pay
lip service to and consider normal, all
right? That is the issue. As long as
that stands, what you're seeing with
Islam has to continue. And by the way,
all of these are problematic issues. The
reason you notice and see, by all of
these I mean the warped, sick ideology
and Islam, which work hand in hand even
though they don't seem to have any
intrinsic connection to one another,
because they don't, other than they are
the other against normalcy. The reason
you don't see it as much as the Islam is
because Islam has is a physical problem.
I did a video a while back. I've been
talking about this and it's very
important to understand that most
Western people, including Christians,
are very much materialists, by which I
mean they only acknowledge and recognize
the material world. And this is the why
this is an issue for Christians, because
Christians claim they believe in the
transcendent metaphysical world. But if
you really look at the way they think
and their actions, they're materialists,
just like an atheist. The only thing
that's real is physical. So, the worst
thing you can do is physically harm
someone. So, that's why they are
starting to see Islam, because Islam is
violent. Islam is physically causing
problems in the West and all throughout
the world, actually, okay? But you what
you don't see and what's a little more
subtle is the evils of this leftist
system, okay? The sexual degeneracy and
depravity and all that, because you've
been socially engineered into only
accepting the material, you don't see
the immoral stuff that's going on.
What's wrong with sexual depravity?
That's freedom, bro, right? What's wrong
with men and women becoming each other?
That's that's cool, that's normal,
because it's not physically violent,
right? It doesn't and you're a
materialist, so you don't get it. You
can't put your finger on it, but you
feel something's wrong. And that's
what's wrong, my friend, okay? So, my
point is you're not the the Islam thing
throughout this whole thing I've told
you theoretically can be handled
including in the most extreme ways which
I'm not necessarily advocating I'm just
saying it could happen but you're not
going to get there as long as this
system governs your way of thinking and
your mind and your very world view and
your very epistemology okay that has to
go first and that's where really the
problem lies that's why you are going to
continue being paralyzed you know look
the West is so strong militarily
economically technologically against
let's say Islam. And it can't do
anything it's paralyzed because of this
sort of intellectual domination and
here's the thing unfortunately you're
not going to you can't will this we
can't just sit here and go well you know
what we're going to will what you say
maybe right but we're going to will
ourselves to go against Islam no you
can't do that right it's all
interrelated this is something that's
going to take generations to fix just
like it took generations to degrade
Western people with all of these
disgusting philosophies okay it's going
to take generations to fix it. Remember
that KGB guy I think he was in the 80s I
forgot his name I watched his videos he
was like an ex-KGB guy who who explained
you know the the actual systematic way
that communism worked consciously which
was you infiltrate a whole society let's
say America and you you convince this
generation whatever generations present
of X Y and Z and then you know the
second generation becomes more
susceptible weaker including with more
propaganda and it's it's seen as an
incremental war. Subversive war it's
it's consciously designed that way
because that's what works and that's
what the West has been suffering from
for decades actually okay but it's going
to be the same way there's no way you're
going to tomorrow wake up and be like
okay everything's overthrown you're
going to this is going to require
education this is going to require
actual education not indoctrination
which is what public schools do it's
going to require a lot of work and it's
important to actually get started there
by all means everyone who is saying what
they're saying about Muslim migration
and saying we're going to do X, Y, and
Z, I'm not against that. Do it, you
know? But, all I'm saying is it's enough
with the words, okay? It's time to see
something, right? Hold them accountable.
All these people who come and tell you,
"I'm going to do this." or "I'm going to
do that." You need to hold them
accountable because it doesn't seem to
me that any of them have done anything
meaningful, okay? And in the meantime,
you need to work on correcting your
society and your worldview and your
philosophies because that's really where
it's at. That's what we need to get
fixed. Once that's fixed, everything
falls into place. If we could go back to
the mentality, let's say from 100 years
ago, that was in Europe and America, the
Islam problem would be solved like that.
Naturally. But, you can't because you're
you're caught up in a in a warped way of
thinking. And so, you can't do what's
right. Bring back the
>> [music]
>> Bring back
Bring back
the fire
>> [music]
>> and the
righteousness name.